I've been telling you for a while Rhonda
santis is dangerous and part of what
makes him dangerous is that he has a lot
of the same terrible authoritarian
instincts of Donald Trump but he is more
able to potentially get things done and
less cartoonishly unhinged appears
Morgan interviewed Ron DeSantis and
remember that Rhonda santis is
experiencing significant shrinkage in
the polls he hasn't actually announced
that he's running yet so this is all
very speculative and very hypothetical
but one of the interesting questions
that was asked by Piers Morgan during
this interview was what are the actual
differences between you and Trump other
Republican candidates and potential
candidates have said there really are no
differences other than identity
Nikki Haley said well I'm younger and a
woman and Indian
Tim Scott said I don't know that I have
any policy differences but here is Ron
desantis's answer to that question what
do you think of the differences well I
mean I think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the the approach to
covid was different I mean you know I
would have fired somebody like fauci uh
I think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important so DeSantis is
essentially saying the difference is our
style and I would have fired fauci not
exactly a big gap between him and Donald
Trump interestingly enough uh Piers
Morgan did ask Ron DeSantis his views on
the nicknames that Trump has come up for
him who's your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it wrong
Rhonda sanctimonious or meatball Rock
well I can't I think even he went off
meatball wrong I can't uh I don't know
how to spell the sanctimonies I don't
really know what it means but I you know
I kind of like it's long it's got a lot
of valve I mean so we go with that
that's fine you know isn't this fun guys
you call me and you can call me whatever
you want I mean just as long as you you
know also call me a winner right right
DeSantis is the winner asked whether he
believes if he were to run oh sorry no I
want to do Putin next the topic of
Vladimir Putin came up and this is very
interesting we'll see a view of pizza
look I think he's got Grand Ambitions I
think he's hostile to the United States
but I think the thing that we've seen is
he doesn't have the conventional
capability to realize his Ambitions and
so he's basically a gas station with a
bunch of nuclear weapons and so for us
one of the things we could be doing
better is utilizing our own energy
resources in the United States we could
be permitting natural gas pipelines from
Marcellus doing a lot in in Alaska
that's where he gets all his power and
obviously he's influenced Europe uh by
by having so much energy so the way to
hit Putin is to hit him with energy but
I do think you look back all the defense
analysts and me in the past we
overestimated his conventional
capability this has been a huge blunder
for him uh huge costs and uh you know
we'll see what ends up happening with
his longevity and and power but but this
has been a this has been a loss for them
there is a move now to hold him
accountable for war crimes bombing
maternity hospitals and genocidal
activity in parts of Ukraine it's wiping
out whole cities maripole and others
which you support that I mean I think he
is a war criminal this ICC we have not
done that in the United States because
we're concerned about our soldiers or
people uh being brought under it but I
do think that he should be held
accountable so uh sort of sounds like
tough talk but a lot of the same caveats
uh that many of the soft Putin Defenders
will kind of reflexively go to including
he's not nearly as dangerous as some
claim him to be so sort of interesting
not in incredibly notable then appears
Morgan does ask DeSantis if you did run
do you think you can beat Trump I think
you can beat bud I think so I'm sorry do
you think you can beat Biden if you did
run I think you could beat bud I think
so so you're running them no I didn't
say that I just said I think I could I
mean I think that that's I mean if you
look at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout
I don't know those are two Okay so
that is very interesting because if you
really do believe that in an election
against the sitting president of the
United States you would win it seems
very difficult to imagine getting away
from getting involved in that race no
matter what the primary polling says so
that's going to uh remain remain to be
seen
um Peters Morgan did ask Ron DeSantis
about allegations
that he backed the force-feeding of
prisoners while serving at Guantanamo
Bay DeSantis says it's not true but he
gets a little mushy-mouthed about it one
of the things I said was that you
authorize the use of force-feeding that
somebody yeah that's not true yeah any
of the stuff that people must have
finished it Force feeding the detainees
they were on Hunger Strike was that true
so I was a I was a junior officer I
didn't have authority to authorize
anything there may have been a commander
that would have done feeding if someone
was going to die but that was not
something that I would have even had
authority to do so that's that's wrong
yeah yeah absolutely okay uh and by the
way DeSantis is saying it's it's a raw
it's wrong to claim he did it not that
it's wrong to do the force feeding and
then lastly asked about Tick Tock and
I'll just play this one for you here
would you ban tick tock
I think so would you I think so I mean I
think from everybody in America I think
I think it's a security risk I think
they are harvesting so much data on our
citizens there's a whole bunch of other
apps and stuff that are out there and
honestly Pierce I got young kids I don't
want our kids on some of this stuff
would you okay so he would indeed ban
Tick Tock listen the danger with
DeSantis is he although he's incredibly
low energy and low charisma
he very casually will present ideas as
though yeah you know yeah yeah okay yeah
and so you always sort of come away like
well he doesn't seem very ideological
because like it sounds like he's sort of
like softly in this camp but he could
easily be pulled over here this is
really the trick of DeSantis where then
when you look at his actual record it's
this wacky anti-woke delusion fighting
the culture wars and extraordinarily
authoritarian as we've covered before so
a very interesting interview because it
shows us the DeSantis that he would
present to the world if he were to run
and it's this very down Earth yeah yeah
I'm a reasonable guy yeah yeah I would
do that I probably would yeah so it
makes sense sure yeah now Putin's bad
but yeah you know he's not really that
bad and that doesn't really have that
much that much power and then the
actions with DeSantis are really the
scary things so a very interesting
interview to see I'm sure there will be
more one of our sponsors is
curiositystream the best place to find
and watch documentaries on politics
history science technology nature you
name it they have it curiosity stream
has a deeper collection of documentaries
than any other streaming service they
add new titles every week including
exclusive award-winning films and shows
you can't watch anywhere else I just
watched ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below